[Music]
people aren't afraid of failing they're
afraid of failing in front of other
people right I think people are so
worried about other people's judgement
that they don't even try and that ends
up being the biggest failure of all and
that's easy to say that's easy to taco
is easy to say yeah I agree but then you
still are afraid and you still do the
thing you're supposed to do so how do
you get over it I think the best way to
inoculate yourself against judgment is
to do it in micro doses so just like
going into the gym you're not gonna go
in and lift a thousand pounds you start
with a two-pound dumbbell and then a
five pound and a ten pound you work your
way up it's the same thing you're not
gonna go off if you're afraid of Judge
Brent you're not gonna go off and do
some big crazy thing you need to start
smaller and so I try to think of what is
one small thing that I'm afraid of
judgment on and then go off and do that
thing and what you'll find is one of two
things one people don't care the people
who you thought would care don't
actually care you don't get as much
backlash as you think you will you get
some people who will support you and
then the negativity that does come when
you can learn to eat it it doesn't feel
as bad like it the fear of it is worse
than it actually being it the the stoic
philosophers used to spend a day I don't
know if there's a day a month or a
couple days a year being homeless just
to know what it feels like to be
homeless because you're so afraid of
losing everything you're being homeless
and then if you are actually homeless
you realize you know what I didn't die
like it's not that bad I can deal with
it I'm stronger than I thought I would
be and so thinking about not what some
crazy bold thing is for you to do I
think that's where we tend to go think
about the smallest possible thing and
every time you feel yourself feeling
that
that fear feeling that you're gonna be
judged then you have to go and do that
thing even if you didn't really want to
because conquering the fear of judgment
is worth
I took my students out to a nail salon
we want a competition a dancing
competition
and they asked me for one to get my
nails done and I said that's ridiculous
so many miles day the only acceptable
answer is this is not an expression of
myself it's not how I choose to express
myself
lingering was the thought I can't get my
nails done I'm a guy we don't get our
nails done I got to make youtube videos
I have meetings with with CEOs and
clients I have a speaking gig like I
can't have my nails done and because
that was one of the reasons why then I
had to do it then I had to get my nails
done just to eat that judgment and then
I did it I mean it felt weird at the
beginning and then I got used to it
and then it started the chip it slowly
started to chip away and especially the
women friends and my circles like all
your nails are chipping you should you
should get that removed and because I
felt their judgment now I had to keep it
on the whole time kept it on the whole
time until it slowly grew and they're
like little chunks of orange on my nails
every now and then I had to keep it on
the whole time just to again inoculate
myself against a fear of judgment
because if I can't handle painting my
nails how am I gonna do something much
bigger
and so what you find is when you feel
the judgment and you do it you actually
start building confidence you start
building self-respect but you're worried
about how do I build the self confidence
self-respect that's how you do it but it
also creates a negative spiral downwards
if you don't do it if you realize I want
to do that I want to go try for that
soccer team but I'm afraid to do it and
then you don't do it you're building
negative respect you're building that
identity if I'm the kind of person who
when I'm afraid I don't do it I don't
follow through so that's when you need
to conquer and as you start doing it
then you'll be able to handle bigger and
bigger things to be able to lift bigger
and bigger bigger weights I think for
the most part we just do things without
realizing we just play small by default
I think we play small by default I think
we're so worried about judging that we
play small by default I think even me I
think many times today I've said no to
something or did not do something out of
judgment and I didn't catch it the more
that you can catch it though and the
more that you do take positive action
the more likely you'll catch it the next
time and the next time you know we'll
handle bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger things
[Music]
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that we believe that
people need passion and not one drop of
myself work depends on your it's
something serene if you liked this video
I think you'll love the video I made on
the 7 toxic habits to avoid in life it's
right next to me go check it out
continue to believe and I'll see you
there and the very first thing that you
do every single morning is slam that
snooze button and tell yourself in the
process that it's okay